me refiero algo que le estaban
preguntando también al primer ministro
británico y es que el g20 no logra
tantos acuerdos y son 20 países como van
a lograr ponerse de acuerdo casi 200
naciones que van a participar en la con
26 de glasgow sabiendo la importancia
que tiene esta cumbre en este momento
para la humanidad
valentina muchísimas gracias por
invitación un saludo muy especial para
la audiencia de france 24 yo creo que
hay un trino que hace muy pocos minutos
escribió antonio guterres secretario
general de las naciones unidas que
resume perfectamente lo que somos viendo
ahorita en ese momento en el g20 roma y
quizás lo que va a venir en el copp 26
en glasgow y es básicamente como dice
gutiérrez salvo con esperanza pero al
mismo tiempo también con la tranquilidad
de que mis ilusiones no fueron
enterradas es decir con escepticismo
frente a lo que puede ocurrir algo que
se ha anunciado que nos digamos que se
pueden emitir una serie de anuncios en
el marco de un evento como el que hemos
presenciado en días recientes pero que
es muy difícil traducir eso a hechos
concretos a acuerdos concretos y además
es muy importante y es que se puedan
cumplir a lo largo de los años y que no
llegue un gobierno más adelante alguno
de sus países clave de la gente de g20 a
cambiar todo como ya lo vimos en eeuu
por parte del expresidente camps que un
día para otro' diego y anunció una serie
de medidas completamente en retiro y
entre digamos en
afectando lo que se había decidido en
anteriores sesiones del g20 y en lo que
se había pactado en el acuerdo de parís
con el retiro de eeuu precisamente el
acuerdo de parís así que es muy difícil
lograr que esto que anuncian muchos
líderes políticos con tanto entusiasmo
lograr que esos realmente se concrete yo
creo que si hay un mensaje de valentina
en ese sentido y es que por lo menos hay
más esperanza de la que veíamos hace uno
o dos años en anteriores reuniones del
g-20